hello welcome back to big mood we're all
here except for boughs missing boats
today we're all rotating out so it's
only for voices instead of five that way
we're not all talking over each other I
think it worked out pretty well last
week with just being gone and then next
week I'll be I'll be out but yeah we got
the four of us you want to introduce
yourselves who's on today for those that
are just an audio yes Tiffany's here she
and this year Gina and I'm Jess and do
you know what he already started I mean
I gotta get my [ __ ] done man
so for those of you who are listening to
audio only you have to come back and
watch the YouTube video too because
every week we've been doing themes and
this week Gina picked a spa theme was on
we're all in our respective spas can you
guess why no I uh I think cuz June is a
lazy [ __ ] and she doesn't want to I was
kind of thankful cuz I didn't wash my
hair for a week and I was like oh I can
put my hair in a terry cloth towel like
okay not to put not to put a bunch of
makeup on I know I have a little bit of
eyeliner on though because if not I get
completely washed out so I'm cheating a
little bit with the eyeliner there who
didn't watch that we were discussing
what you should do I said Spa and buzz
like oh my god what'd she do like those
black charcoal masks and just immediate
was like no I am NOT getting cancelled
free spa themed one good for you
mine's purple is just wait wait I hope
this doesn't look like a bad color on
camera
Gina's mask is still blackface on Jess I
would have leave on masks on so I'm just
you doing okay and sit down accent nah
girl this is a really rushed concealer
and because I have a pimple here you can
see the shadow a little bit so I'm like
I'm not I'm just doing a little
something no I can't see you can't see
[ __ ] no it was great
I do have to say that my skin has been
so bad since the corn yeah
never broken out as bad as I have in the
last week's ever same Jess what is that
I have no idea maybe just maybe just
last name circulating air the holes yeah
exactly
being clean though like I tell something
Jess are you eating junk food yeah what
is been your go-to junk food or double
stuffed Oreos I'm talking about I eat
these ruffles they're pretty they're
like a new flavor well not super new but
they've only been out for like less than
a year I think they're hot wings all
your ruffles only extra crunchy and then
I eat that with sour cream I've been
eating the [ __ ] out of these hot wings
flavored ruffles I was doing everyone
listening changing their pantry junk
food Gina I've been eating a lot of
avocado and dude no I'm like but
actually no boozy [ __ ] were you getting
avocado no bro anchor Cena they brought
so many a religion Oh actually I lie
I've been carb loading like dude me too
I've been eating way too much sugar
that's way too much sugar so much
chocolate I usually don't eat that much
chocolate but I think just because you
know we're here and it's there it's so
good my go-to has been hot cheetos with
cream cheese
he'll you [ __ ] yeah on my level right
there yeah pounds I want a [ __ ] diary
yeah I got the four pounds I'm just
going to weigh myself I never weigh
myself I actually think I lost weight
but I got like skinny fat like you know
where it's all flabby but it like I'm
smaller because I'm eating less calories
I think cuz I'm only eating cookies dude
I don't leave my house that's what
happened but I went through all the
daily harvest meals so I really did love
those I actually ordered some more but
they're taking a while to get in because
you know shipping times are just like
really delayed because of everything
going on and and so yeah I've just been
ordering a lot of post mates and then
whatever like doesn't go bad in the
pantry and guess what
Oreos don't go bad and Mari they're just
chocolate no but I've been loving to mix
up two cans of tuna with one can of corn
like the kernel corn and then whole
bunch of mayo and I put that on saltine
crackers and then as my snacks dude
doner stacks seriously what that sounds
like some white people [ __ ] that even I
don't want to eat I'm sorry I go - it
was a go-to snack in my my thinking
household so consider this a remix but
it is not which is making a tongue
sandwich so I have a weird sandwich
combination it's so white bread Wonder
Bread cuz we're poor and mayonnaise on
it with whatever like lunch meat that
you like like turkey or whatever cheese
and then here's kicker peanut butter
trash because actual garbage that's true
but you gotta add the chili in there to
balance it bomb don't know if retry it
around like a pregnant lady's yeah
you're eating pickles of peanut butter
actually pretty good oh I'm the pregnant
lady okay well I've been pregnant is
this coming from TIFF we just said she
mixing mixing - no at corn and she yeah
did you all see that bass baby on
Twitter
[Applause]
yeah I saw that big big big-ass [ __ ]
baby I was like huh Twitter hates that
baby I hate that
not literally right obviously because
it's just terrified ursin but like one
of us it was so girls like seeing the it
was bouncing on his dad or whoever it
was just floating out his diaper and I
was just like yeah but baby listen he
already has a mortgage that baby is so
weird yeah I don't want a Joel drew but
it is the most hilarious thing ever like
rosing a baby oh my god Gerald's
roasting a baby
guys people are going I get it but I'm
terrified of that baby if I saw it being
said in my room the middle that I Oh cry
it I was conflicted when I saw a baby
because I'm like that's someone's child
why does baby a background so people
could see honestly TIFF I never even
thought about it being a child or a
human being I just went straight into I
was just like oh my god talking about
that today alright here's the baby she
is cute he feels like like he seems like
he's gonna be a really nice man like
next year next year she's gonna be a
really nice man construction no he looks
like he's hitting on me at the bar
clearly a mother okay I mean yeah it
looks like it just went through his
first divorce and he's like picking up
on Gina go missing out although we do
appreciate you guys you should not just
be listening to the audio version you
need to come back though and listen to
audio and then come back and see the
images that
yeah I'm getting dry and crusty tail
that's bad you're saying my your face
mask or just in general I'm talking
about my [ __ ] so long our topic is
actually going to be about children and
Parenthood up right to here yes well our
friend to hear more has a has a much
light it's just [ __ ] them kids are you
serious
yeah it's something like a whole
sentence but then if you get the first
letter of each sentence no thanks
drinking tequila from the bottle but at
least is classy tequila bottle she's
just wondering $30 a bottle she's like I
don't wanna be able to afford this 130
to you you know but not having kids
right now see on Saturday night in this
quarantine I got absolutely shit-faced
like woke up at 5 a.m. puked and went
back to bed [ __ ] whoa Oh 17 further I
was playing video games my friends got
absolutely trashed knocked out woke up
puking with bats and woke up feeling
like a cheetah you like a Geisha right
now and you're in your robe and the red
lips yeah so I thought that was really
interesting because just brought this up
on in our group chat the other day and
that's kind of how we decided on this
topic because
TIFF and I had been trying in our
respective marriages to conceive and
have children I mean Lee Chan so yeah
not wouldn't each others miss out hope
so
there's no exchanges going on here
yeah and then during this quarantine we
both stopped and when Jess brought up
that she's like I don't know if I ever
want to have kids
honestly Steve and I have been having
similar conversations even though we've
always been family people you guys were
trying this year though right yeah so
it's [ __ ] is it the quarantine that
shifted your thoughts entirely or is it
something else well I feel like there's
a window and right now has been the
window right where like I'm 33 right now
so I feel like if we want to have two
kids or any more than one kid you kind
of just have to do it in this window
but then the quarantine stuff happened
and yeah it's like I'm kind of scared to
go to a doctor and go to the hospital
and like go through the whole process
and you if you get pregnant right now
people are giving birth alone like you
don't get your husband in there with you
you don't get like your midwife no one
gets to be in there with you it's like
you're giving baby comes out no chip
tries to steal the mask cuz it's tiny
she loves it yeah there's this one photo
I mean I don't know where I don't know
how to put it but I saw one photo on
Twitter where it was a like a like a
slideshow kind of thing of quarantine
baby like baby that we're born during
this time and they all have like tiny
little masks there are like a little
shield first all the shields in Thailand
or with all the shields I can even dot I
saw one that dog's head have a bunch of
like see now like covers I'm like oh my
god that's so cute but they can't
breathe through their nose so that's
kind of hard they have to be like so
breathe yeah oh wait maybe it's wait no
no right it's the other way around cats
can't breathe through their mouths there
we go we got it really can breathe
through their nose oh yeah yeah cats
don't breathe through their mouths they
can't know right they just don't I've
seen it before
really yeah they're overheated maybe I'm
just over here making about animals like
a drunk and I can't remember if I read
something or if I just had a thought in
my head seems like it because my cat
snores directly into my [ __ ] ear Wow
every night my cats or - sorry - my cats
what - I thought my girl cat had a
breathing problem like we should take
her the vet because she's freaking loud
well I guess nothing right now I think
right now my cat is as far as I'm gonna
go with kids because I am okay so here's
a memory I like last time we talked
about this among 10 inches all right
yeah that's right was that one christina
was on yeah excuse mom and then because
I was like what I get old I'm gonna for
someone to take care of me so I don't be
alone you know be nice you know
you guys have been something to me yeah
right and also now lately I've been
thinking like or I cannot have kids
save all my money do whatever the [ __ ] I
want with it and if I blow it all before
like right before I died dope I live a
great life if I don't blow it out and
farted I'll just give it to my sister my
nieces and nephews or something [ __ ]
dead oh dude like I don't know I don't
I'm thinking about it and I get the
whole love thing and that's the one
thing that I have no argument for is
like oh this is a love you'll never
experience and I'm sure TIFF can attest
to that literally every other part of it
I'm like [ __ ] no no and it's been my 30s
at Chuck E Cheese every weekend um I
think that the only reason that I still
want to have kids I think we're still
going like we still got we're still
going to have kids I've always planned
on it it's just right now it just feels
like the wrong move but yeah that I am a
really big proponent of living your life
fully
so like doing all the things that you
can do in life so if I can have kids
like I do want to have that experience I
do like no I don't want to get to the
end of my life and regret something you
know yeah I feel like I would get to the
end of my life and regret having kids I
would be like [ __ ] maybe
oh my body they stole my [ __ ] money
just don't have kids don't high key you
know what something I'm really scared of
I know that TIFF has brought this up
before about like getting scared of her
kid murdering her but I'm not scared of
my kid murdering me I'm scared of them
being like codependent with
some like gangster dude that like you
know I watch these crime shows where
like they get together with a boyfriend
that and the boyfriend convinces them
that they're better off without their
parents and like we should you know we
should murder them and take their money
and like the daughter was going along
with it and then like at the end of it
they're like the daughter is like I
don't know how I got entranced by this
guy and like he you know he hypnotized
me into the leaving all this jacket is
your daughter yeah okay Lifetime TV
you've been watching too much
I will judge your choices Jeana so I
would appreciate it is step back like a
million to one chance Nicki your
scenario I mean so does the get your kid
killing you it's like come on that
that's like the most it's true but you
[ __ ] up hard if your kids not zero no
because there are some good parents and
their kids just go [ __ ] crazy
yeah I really don't like their parents
yeah that's right if that's a I so that
was a gene you can't you don't know if
you what I what
no I was gonna say you look like an ICP
fan but go ahead and continue I am not
heavy enough to be a Juggalo right now I
know you're a baby or a Juggalo you're
getting arrested today know what you
signed up for babies don't use Twitter
we can rode their free-for-all saga
litter terribly no they're too busy like
having cult surveillances or whatever
right someone ticked off they're doing
terrible tits up oh yeah well you got to
find something show it to us
they think that ICP has like profit
prophetic album covers because like
supposedly predicted 9/11 all kinds of
other stuff so they're like the last ICP
CD is the end of the world
so I don't know maybe they did release
it this year in toys because I would
if if by some [ __ ] weird odd
occurrence that Juggalos predict at the
end of the world I'm going to off myself
before I would even happen no hell no
I'll just go find the most alpha Juggalo
and be otherwise it is the biggest one
by the way Juggalos [ __ ] what um
started the whole thought process of you
deciding you don't want to have kids
[ __ ] what was that I think I think
when the quarantine started I started
spending a lot more time to myself and
just I you know when you like finally
get rid of all of the noise in your head
it does help you to reflect on your life
and and I don't think that it's because
I'm assuming the world is not going to
be good because of the quarantine or I'm
worried about the virus or nothing like
that I think it's just more that I
really sat down and realize like why
would I want to have kids and it never
came from anything really personal it
came from like that's something I should
do and I don't want to I don't want to
sound like less of a woman or be like a
weird no no that doesn't fit in he has
no desire to have a chill children and I
just really thought like Oh like if I'm
rushing because I have a biological
deadline I'm going to be making
decisions I wouldn't normally make
trying to like force a man to fit into
the whole like like a square peg into a
round hole so I can make this marriage
happen and her you can make this kid's
situation happen and I'm like I guess
I'm not gonna say never say never but
what I'm basically doing is just
completely letting go of the idea yeah I
think that's great I think there
shouldn't be that pressure at all I mean
there is but I know I can go society but
I really do think that it's when you let
go and looks like let life happen the
way it's supposed to is like when it's
you're in tune with your choices and
everything moving forward I definitely
would not consider kids at all if I
wasn't with Steve and felt like I don't
yeah so it just doesn't i would total
it's being babies don't make sense
logically they just know like really
they are just a product of love or
mistakes like one of the to look and
they're happening stupid like they don't
know how to do math actually a lot of
kids are way better at math and most of
us right now i bet if we test some kids
they would be way smarter than all of us
at putting together apps like designing
apps I'm like damn Welsh I was raised in
this era but yeah like I've seen I've
known quite a few couples who got
married because okay it's the right
thing to do I should and have kids
pieces right things you it's the Korean
the Korean parents pressure and bro
they're like miserable just yeah yeah I
mean if I think back on like a lot of
people from high school right now look
at them on Facebook and I'm like they
definitely rushed to have kids and then
now there's thirty three and they're
divorced for their first time you know
their first divorce with these kids and
then and I'm just like man everyone felt
so pressured to follow this timeline and
now it's falling apart and crumbling
around me and I'm kind of like I don't
really you know like what am I really
shooting for at this point I'm already
over that 30s hump so it's like I don't
know if I were even really need to worry
about it TRT wants to like freeze my
eggs as a maybe yeah that's a good idea
a lot of people do that my girlfriend
does that and the process seems like a
[ __ ] sucks and it's a pay like every
month to store it so I mean so maybe
like you know maybe I'll do it but no
I'm kind of I'm kind of whatever about
kids right now and like you know it is I
like having my money to myself yeah that
really is it sleeping mm-hmm yeah and
have sex
loud hmm I kind of want to hear from
tips on the other side of some of them
all have a kid who is a mom who knows
the pleasures of being a parent and like
she's just listening to all this
ignorant [ __ ] not having kids I've
been getting my up to just having kid
[ __ ] expensive [ __ ] well night he
doesn't have a car yet and he
not going to college it and all of that
other [ __ ] yeah not yet but um yeah I've
just been sitting here and I'm listening
to you like all you guys and I'm like I
probably would be saying the same thing
if I didn't have a kid - yes it's hard
to see it from the other side when
you're not there so yeah but for me was
the best thing about having kids
although yeah so okay well you guys know
I had Isaac when I was 18 so I brought a
life into the world when I was really
young I'm not I'm not prepared at all
but somehow I did it and the honestly
like every hurdle every every tough
situation like any moment that I felt
like oh my god what's the point like I
just have to give up this is too hard
like I can't [ __ ] do this like zero
support I would just look at Isaac and
like you would give me this like moment
where I'm like this dude's out of the
movies like no wonder people portrayed
us in movies but there would be these
moments like he'll stare at me or he'll
come up to me be like mommy this or like
show me something or like just like this
moment of pure like like innocent human
life like this like you love coming from
this person that you need it's like it's
[ __ ] mind-blowing like that long I'm
getting emotional but it's right right
what is maybe every single struggle like
every single hurdle like it makes it so
much lighter because it's like I'm not
living just for me you know about
dressing nice to go and like crush up
all my birth-control hills north that's
all right now [ __ ] okay no we're talking
about such fix we're talking about
stitch fix one of our sponsors who we
love thank you we love gonna be a
well-dressed mother in with this fashion
changes guys true style never changes
though even so you're timeless look can
use a pick-me-up every once in a while
get help get help from someone who gets
what you're going for with
out ever leaving the home which we can't
even do that anyway so with the stick
stitch fixed by the hardest thing to say
with a stitch thick styling expert you
can get some fashion help there a
personal styling company and they bring
you to the world of fashion there's so
many different fun ways to find clothes
that you will love every time to get
started you can set up a profile
basically what you do is you go through
and you just you'll say like I like this
kind of stuff I don't like this kind of
stuff there's even they'll show you a
ton of pictures too of like do you like
this shirt and it's almost like tender
you just go swipe yes or spike no no
thumbs-up thumbs-down don't like it and
then they'll just send you a curated box
and you get to pick from that box if you
like everything you get a little bit of
a discount to so I love their jeans
their jeans are so comfortable jeans are
so popular I feel like they own those
jeans because they're so comfy I have
never found a pair of jeans that fit me
so well dude yeah I think those are one
of my favorite pairs that I have in my
closet for sure stitch fix does all the
hard work for you making great style
effortless for everybody including women
men and kids I didn't know that they did
many kids before so that's pretty cool
to get started today go stitch fix calm
slash mood and get an extra 25% off when
you keep everything in your box
that's stitch fix calm slash mood one
more time
stitch one stitch big step cut class zu
/ mood damn they're just kids - Tiffany
can Joseph Isaac and they fly over it I
love it what else can we get from the
comfort of our home well when you were
hungry thank you for asking Jess for
passing it over to me because we have
over here - so now with the be
quarantine everything I've been ordering
a lot door - so you can continue
supporting restaurants in your community
safely there are thousands of
restaurants open for your delivery or
for delivery on board - that need your
patronage now more than ever support
your favorite restaurants in BER - I've
been support
a lot of my Asian restaurants nearby and
honestly I would not be able to survive
right now without and we know you can't
cook for two No yeah oh no I can't go to
surprise surprise so door dashing that
is an app that brings you food that
you're craving right now right to your
door ordering is easy just open the app
choose what you want to eat and your
food will be left safely outside your
door
with a new contact list delivery
drop-off setting there's over 300
thousand partners in u.s.
Puerto Rico Canada and Australia
Australia your local goat cheese -
cheese from your favorite national that
sounds like Chipotle Wendy's and the
Cheesecake Factory about that goddamn
Cheesecake Factory I love me some
Cheesecake Factory so right now our
listeners can get five dollars off their
first order of $15 or more and zero
delivery fees for their first month when
you download the door - app and enter
the code big mood that's five dollars
off first order and zero delivery fees
for the first month when you download
the door - app in the App Store and
enter the code big mood that is big mood
for five dollars off your first order
weird or - oh yeah can i watch this can
i watch this stuff off my face go ahead
I'll go next okay
BRB alright so jester stick took her
mask off Gina's taking her mask off now
and update us Jess how was that clay
mask the clay mask
it feels pretty good it's a little I
mean I usually don't use clay masks cuz
I already have dry skin that's like kind
of a little bit irritated a lot but
because I've been having so many pimples
I thought it would be good but because
it is a little bit drying because clay
is always drying I think I'm gonna put
on now a follow-up mask which is this
honey mask it's a Korean cute it's
called a sleeping pack so I guess I'm
supposed to leave it on for like
permanently asleep yeah but never ever
ever take it off pretty sticky is it
sticky
only its on the consistency wait well if
you can its viscosity
its viscosity it's kind of like I would
say no it's not like it
it smells like pears or something but
it's supposed to be honey with a
blueberry flavor so huh yeah so you just
took all the moisture out so you could
put the moisture in yeah [ __ ] yeah
because masks face masks were pretty
pointless so you know they're just fun
great I think I'm gonna have a sticky
looking face now it's not sticky though
actually it's pretty soft yeah your face
looks like like that glass skin trend
yeah sorry hold on I gotta get my dog to
stop barking sit down sit down
I don't know why she thinks barking is
this a like a glimpse into anyway yeah
no wonder you don't want kids cuz you
have dogs that's like kids I know I
can't even deal I can't even deal with
my own dogs I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ]
murder you if you don't stop barking
right now there cats are pretty chill
and quiet calm down Casey and love they
don't [ __ ] about anything honestly part
of me thinks I might be the type of mom
to drown her kids so I just shouldn't
have oh wow now who's getting cancelled
know if I'm doing the public a service
by not having children they should
applaud me no I thought you were gonna
say a public service by drowning my
children I do not condone murder I don't
condone murder I mean like a little bit
nice oh whoa I mean we don't know what
kind of videos but there are moments
when
yeah being a parent doesn't if you want
to pull your hair out so I talked about
that beautiful sight but you guys want
me to hear about the all its ugly side
cuz that's I want to hear it all TIFF I
want to hear a little bit because I want
to know that I'm right in my decision
all right I want to feel good about
myself honestly okay for me personally
my journey as a as a parent it's been
interesting because it has allowed me to
reflect on the type of person I am like
my character my morals like just
everything that I realized that I had to
learn about myself because I'm actually
passing it down on to someone else where
am I whoa I never had to like think
about like sometimes a license I'm
really interesting like more like ethics
kind of questions I don't ban I'm like
okay well it's like this because it's
like this and then he'll be like what
why and I'm like well because that's
just the right thing to do I don't like
the answers for everything
but it is why all the time yeah but then
he gets um it's challenging for sure so
it's that's kind of one of the headaches
but then also now that he's getting
older and he's becoming a little
teenager and he you know just attitude
and stuff I'm like I'm not totally good
with me that will go how do you deal
with the teenager without fighting your
kid dude well it's what you have to talk
to them and try to feed a friend but
also like find that fine balance like
that fine line you have to stand out
whatever you might I mean um it's like
being disciplinary and also being their
friend like being someone that they can
feel safe and that they can go to and
they trust but for some reason I can't
freaking find that balance because they
think like I don't know do you think
feels like they found that but I think I
am pretty good like yeah I admire your
ability to be so open with Isaac and
Gina what's a
have a moment Gina Steele I like that
you are really open with Isaac I
remember my my mom was really would
never talk down to me she would never
like you know some people go like hi
like do you need something
snack like should always talk to me like
an adult and so it made me feel like I
could express things and and not I
wasn't my voice was heard you know and I
always got really weirded out when other
adults would talk down to me you know I
feel like I would have an issue like at
Isaac's age being a parent cuz I would
be so petty and like such an [ __ ] I
don't think I could be like an
authoritative figure who like is the
right thing I think it would be like
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] like like [ __ ] off
you know like I can't imagine myself
like holding back and like being able to
have like a measured like not fighting
or hit below the belt
oh [ __ ] you don't know [ __ ]
you know I same especially when they're
like 20 harm and they think that like
let's so people other really relative
when you're doing though I feel like you
think you know everything you're like
okay I'm ready grown like I pretty much
know myself I mean I've always felt like
I knew myself but then like when you get
older you really know yourself and
you're like oh sure you know anything
back then especially when you're like
going to college and you're around other
people that just think they know
everything to like you just are in a
group of people that think they know
everything and then later you realize
you were a [ __ ] dumbass and it's not
until later that you appreciate it so
like all the people that I pissed off
probably when I was 20 when they were
like 35 or something and I was like yeah
they you're an old person I'm now like
oh damn some of those people they kind
of knew something we're so douchey and
our 20 is like god I think that's the
age I'm gonna struggle with raising a
kid the mo
when they get to like that know-it-all
age I don't have nothing at age two I'm
getting there
it's like closer and closer sometimes
days will go by where I'm telling Isaac
okay don't forget you gotta do your
chores or whatever and he goes okay mom
it's just you know sometimes it annoys
me when you tell me and I'm like oh hell
no like no talks of you like that
there's but it's because like I think
with me and Isaac's relationship because
of the fact that I was so young when I
had him I've always treated him like my
little buddy and so it's not necessarily
like that like oh my mom I can
authoritative figure where I need to
respect and she's an elder and not just
that but Isaac was raised around a lot
of adults because there was like barely
any kids on my side there was on his
dad's side but like for the most part
he's just used to hanging around adults
and being near them like he feels older
than kind of like an equal yeah yeah so
sometimes like Casey struggles a lot
with that whole dynamic because he he's
pretty grew up in Texas so it's like sir
and ma'am and like all that stuff's of
Casey struggles with how Isaac has grown
up and how he sees himself as an equal
with us and yeah it's it's hard man not
and then every kid is different too
which is really [ __ ] scares me that
is scary another kid I'm like are we
really gonna roll the dice this is Isaac
really you're like a really good kid
compared to God what you could have
wound up with like you got really lucky
and also you somehow did things right
you know like even being so young like I
figured I think it's just your natural
like you just you as a person is a good
person so like you did a good job
regardless but it's like it's the whole
like flipping a the die or tossing the
dice on like rolling a really good eye
some fun whether or not you're gonna get
the psychopathy gene in the next baby
who's gonna be a whole different story
yes I think what I'm afraid of is like
one like well how the kids going to have
but also I'm afraid of the world for the
kid like having a girl is terrifying to
me because the rule is oh god some of
the [ __ ] [ __ ] wins in my eyeball all
girl ever
the world is whole box unzoom because it
is she has a gold mask on and then she's
got a gold mouth guy in the background
and it's remedy that nothing the [ __ ]
serum just went survival okay like you
played so much with it you're over there
like squishing it with that that with
the cold thing yeah the Jade thing yeah
[ __ ] scary man like like it's it's
scary even in your own family there's
creeps in your family who's creeps out
in the world is like yeah you know like
I can't hold my kid's hand 24/7 like
when she grows up she's got friends like
what if she sucks miles of dick one
night you know there's nothing wrong -
that I don't want him to beat my record
like that's not okay but like you know
what if she goes out one night she's
like alright cool try heroin
you know what I mean like it's dude
that's another one of my parental
struggle struggles is the fact that I I
created this human this human came out
of me I have raised this human all these
years and for so many years out of his
life he would just do anything that I
say it like whatever any way that I
would guide him he would listen all the
time but then now he's getting older you
know obviously he's his own person but
just realizing that he's his own person
and I had to respect paint himself like
as his own being that that sometimes I
forget like I struggle with it where I'm
like what he used to listen to me a list
all the time I used to just blind me
like okay but then now he is like his
own ideas his own opinion his own
questions where I'm like oh [ __ ] I've
got to work with this thing cuz you're
so different
yeah it was like there's like a whole
decade where you can control them and
then after that you can only guide them
sort of yeah yeah it's it's the struggle
but I don't know like I said before it
like every struggle that happens like
scene of the day it's always worth it
because he'll hug come and hug me and
give me the biggest kiss and tell me I
told you you're the greatest mom alive
like is it like Christmas is just more
fun like I don't know when I had a big
family I've always had a big family and
steve has a big family he has a lot of
siblings I have a lot of cousins and we
always did our Christmases like with all
the cousins and stuff we'd spend the
night at my aunt's house we'd wake up
all together like so as a big family and
now all the kids are grown up like we're
all in our 20s and 30s and like some my
brother just had a baby and like some of
the cousins are having babies
so there's babies now and Christmases
got so much more fun again cuz for a
while they were kind of boring like
there's no kid to open up presents and
there's no one getting excited about
Christmas me we're all good dear uncle
the night before and we're happy and
then we're like when we have to wake up
Christmas morning we're like oh man I
can see that I can see the like I mean
there's a whole like experiencing the
childhood again vicariously through your
child but yeah I just don't feel like I
have any interest in things like
honestly like Disneyland repulses me
like all of it like I just you know it's
a closed you wait and understands just
understands first of all blinds are
outside hot he's over price forgetting
the Megan wonder at the Maury I think I
didn't have a magical childhood so
there's nothing for me to be like no
this is great
gene is gapes little Disney movies is
mine I never watched Disney I was
watching beavis and butt-head I liked
you gotta find parking there's people
standing way too close to you
everything's just so - you just gotta
get rich is it's in your goal to get
rich okay by the time you have kids'll
be written down and then you don't have
to do with any of that because dude
Disneyland is ruined for me now because
we we Steve and I used to like work with
maker studios and then they got bought
by Disney and once a year they would
take us all on a Disney day or we would
get assigned to a tour guide and that
[ __ ] you don't wait in any lines you
just tell them where you want to go they
take you right in front of every single
line they like anywhere any restaurant
you want to go eat at you just eat there
it's amazing but then we try to no one
I'm gonna know because I'm just sitting
in the [ __ ] red like I have no
Saltine what you want on the board right
don't go and then like when you when you
when you go on vacation you have to
select the [ __ ] Disneyland Resort in
Hawaii instead of some bomb-ass [ __ ]
like I don't have Disneyland Resort in
Hawaii unless they want to sponsor a
source of Disney's [ __ ] amazing is
the most magical places one I [ __ ]
love Disney movies my name is gene I
love Disney they always sponsor me I
love you of course what I love is having
a nice nice furniture in my house that
I'm worried about kids ruin it yeah
that's me the most the most solid piece
of furniture it is this bed right here
behind the ready can't really see if it
like if you look on the bottom it's all
completely walnut wood it's solid wood
it's so sturdy and so great and it's
from article or sports article and they
they have just the most beautiful
mid-century modern and slash
Scandinavian
textile furniture which is exactly my
style I like to add a little bohemian
accents here and there but mid-century
modern is exactly my style and what I
like is that there is fair prices you
save up to 30% over traditional retail
prices because article is able to keep
the prices low by cutting out the
middleman and selling directly to you
with no showrooms no salespeople no
retail markups it's it's fast there's
affordable shipping available across the
u.s.
in Canada and it's free on orders of
over $9.99 all in stock items are
delivered in two weeks or less which is
insane for a furniture company I don't
know if I ordered furniture from people
yeah they usually take like months like
if you go follow a lot of furniture
companies on Instagram and all their
comments are just people complaining
about how many months where's my food or
where's my furniture yeah and this was
pre quarantine time this was like wow to
be on time right and their team of
designers focus on beautifully crafted
pieces quality materials and they're
just really dedicated to their aesthetic
which I just really appreciate and right
now article is offering our listeners
$50 off your first purchase of $100 or
more go to article comm slash big mood
and the discount will be automatically
applied at check out
that's article comm slash big mood to
get $50 off your first purchase of $100
or more else what's awesome you wanna
know what else I wanna know so guys
Stephanie I might poop myself not smell
bad Jeana not be Nikki so native it's
safe it's a deodorant and it smells
amazing as you can see from the back
right here a good word title in their
last since flavors like heaven lavender
and rose
yeah so like I said it's safe it's
formulated without aluminum parabens or
telc
it's also vegan / never tested on
animals and it's made with ingredients
that you have actually heard of like
coconut oil and shea butter yeah so yeah
so making a switch to aluminum free
deodorant does not mean you have to
sacrifice a performance because native
will keep you smelling and feeling fresh
all day long they have over 10 scents
including their classics and they also
have rotating seasonals
so for sure you will find something that
you absolutely love my personal favorite
is coconut and vanilla right here and
honestly it's actually kind of hard to
choose because lavender rose is bomb and
so it's equal
no the cucumber one that one's the best
one I'm in the Mandarin right yes it's
so good so there's no risk to try free
shipping on every order and they offer
30 days free return slash exchanges in
the USA so if you're still not convinced
you can check out over nine thousand
five strong reviews from many happy
customers so for 20% off your first
purchase visit native deodorant calm and
use promo code big mood during checkout
again for 20% off your first purchase
visit native theatre calm and use promo
code big mood during checkout yay um one
thought I had during this quarantine is
I've been doing a lot more crafts than
normal because I love crafts I have a
whole closet full of crafts but I hardly
ever have time to do them so now that
we've been in quarantine I've been
rediscovering all of my craft stuff but
I swear to God even though I'm very
thankful to not have kids during this
time because I enjoy the peace and quiet
every time I do a freaking craft I think
about how I'm gonna like show my kid one
day like think about that so often like
when I'm cooking I just picture a little
kid helping me cook and being like hey
this is how you crack an egg or this is
how you mix in the flour and every time
I learn something I just can't wait to
share it and so I do mom yeah that's how
you know you were meant to be alone I do
feel that way and I've also never
enjoyed young people stuff like going
out to clubs or like partying and stuff
I'm actually really happy in my 30s
because I feel like I was always in my
30s just stuck in a 20-something body
before and so yeah I feel like this
nurturing side has always been there and
I know that one day it's gonna happen
but I'll tell you what Jess I feel you
oh there's no kids think during
quarantine dunno like you describing
that sounds like a foreign language I'm
like oh you've thought about like you've
pictured a child while you're doing
things like literally never have I ever
thought about hanging out with a kid
and when I see kids I go away used my
nieces or nephews yes I do and I like
never talk to them kids who just can't
see have someone to tell what to do
a crotch Goblin Gina yeah Josh : it's
just like what she's referred to them as
kids you mean I'm a personal slave yeah
I can call you down from upstairs
just to turn off the light in my room
you know I mean girl but that's about a
good decade before they get that useful
I mean I barely touched your mine that's
true I like more investment on her on
your return my friends are convinced
that if I ever were to have a kid I
would be like that Asian tiger mom you
would I would be very mean Danny or you
mean party mom
no cuz I'm not about that [ __ ] I don't
picture that at all like I totally think
Georgina being like supermom nurturing
and so because she's so soft and like so
like loving and like we're you know that
we know don't I know it
don't talk about that I know I'm doing a
secret marshmallow
you're ruining her Brant if she treats
our cat portrait really good day let's
do the nibbler portrait yeah it's so
cute she interrupts himself the prince
himself long may he reign
oh my god Gina cannot sit there and tell
me that she's gonna treat her kid poorly
well I know that beat their ass every
cuz you believe it are the same way
David you David so you always talk about
how you're gonna be your kids ass and
all this stuff but this song was it come
on because softest little [ __ ] I'm
not gonna beat my kid because he's a bad
kid because I'll raise him well it's not
because I in some days he's a bad kid
I'm gonna beat him because it's my turn
pass on the cycle of abuse yeah I might
survive it's fine we all survive it
we're good I'm gonna go back to Clemens
yeah see simple character well we're all
rotating and getting cancelled so yeah
we're all here's the thing what I'm
gonna do is if I want to have kids I'm
gonna drop their ass off at one of your
houses once I'm jumping into your house
you're not do not call me Theo Jess just
this I don't exist when you have
children you're white you're not fun on
your what your auntie just and then we
got dia TIFF and then we got Deepa I
will stop I am the eldest yeah you are
her barely just barely gives you it just
gives your kid a beer for the first time
like under the table they're like she's
like I don't tell your mom three years
old just three nothing tequila is in the
boot King in the background and you're
like what happened I'm like I'll know
something's wrong as you're sipping your
own yet I don't know she gives him a ton
of benadryl to knock about like what
happened to your son he can't he can't
handle look right he's awake from her
tequila bottle there - I'm sure about
God
oh no okay okay I am very happy being
though that aunt the travels the world
and she stops by during Christmas same
yeah like you know like either I'm
married or have a new boyfriend every
Christmas every Christmas I will say my
sweet life like cuz I have a lot of
nieces and nephews now within the past
like four or five years a bunch of
babies just got born and they freaking
love you and you're the aunt cuz you're
like a country you're like not their
dumb parents that they have to see every
day you're like a treat that comes over
and especially if you give gifts so I
give like cheeba like stupid target
gifts that like I just thought other
dumb faces with when I was like
transitive
like they get so happy they're so
excited than my one nice
she's almost five now but she was the
first grandchild born and all of her
favorite Disney movies yeah I said
Disney are like the dark princesses
so she like loves jasmine and Moana and
like all princess Sofia I guess is the
Hana yeah and so she has all of her
dolls of those princesses and when I
come over she brings all the dark
princesses out she puts them out to me I
see like he really treats me like I have
a princess weird interrupts some other
lion it is really sweet like when Isaac
is small and you just come over me for
hugs and like I love you kid yeah and
like he actually softened Joe up like
people yeah cuz I remembered like the
first time I was like what up son he's
like hi and eventually he'll be like
come here you give me a hug it's so cute
shake everyone's a real softy underneath
there yeah yeah cuz honestly like before
I mean I was still a child but before
Isaac I wasn't about kids that much I
wasn't very like a natural like
nurturing motherly kind of person I
guess I kind of was cuz I helped raise
my my younger brothers but I was really
Stern with them like I wasn't very like
motherly I guess I don't know but if I
didn't have Isaac like I don't I don't
know if I would have had kids like right
now I probably wouldn't I don't know
Nikki has no names I've totally can't
even though I don't want kids it's
totally we picked up this year one we
have names for both children better
disgustingly cute but you guys Steve
he's been on jakey news a bunch of times
and he's like we're not gonna tell you
what the names are yeah oh really oh I
know what they are ah man I have seen
something [ __ ] terrible
I've seen some such terrible [ __ ]
names I feel like these people just not
have choice Jeana says the name of okay
oh yeah that's what's the least favorite
name you've ever heard you bro I can't
say it we all know who it is
can we know this what what is it like we
don't know anyone with a weird name do
it oh oh yes we do Wow yeah no one can
no one can see the zoom chat oh I might
know who it is but I'm much when I was
younger
Gina when I was younger and I thought oh
oh but it's not who you guys think we're
talking about no no no they're not
related to her group at all no no no no
what I feel like the first time I saw
that name I got legitimately angry like
why don't you just punch your child in
the face while you're at it when she's
in a tick-tock trend going around with
how white people will pick out their
kids names no je l'ai yeah what's it so
they take a regular basic name like
James or whatever and they and they i GH
Mme yeah every possible way that you can
pronounce the syllables and there's a
grid on YouTube of every possible way
and then they pick like a random ass
formation of the syllable so what is
going on to me it looks like they just
vomited consonants inside of it like
there's extra G's yes isn't all that
[ __ ] wise oh okay I know an example
cuz Casey and I have we been to the
brand new charmed show and on a puss
I love charm anyway there was this one
character her name was Nancy but it was
filled with the cage and with the OEE or
something I was like oh like nice like
how it's like okay and yeah let me see
if I can spell it away I feel like okay
here's the thing with me like if I got
like a cool unique name what the [ __ ] is
that
can't Oh fancy Kanzi but I think I might
as well they're wrong cuz it was
primarily an KN KN like a nice KN yeah
probably
or like nob but I would not want to go
through my life saying like no it's
actually spelled like this and it's
pronounced like this yeah Aaron I used
to get pissed off when girls would be in
my class and their name was Jessica also
there was one girl her name was gess ika
and
like oh hey your name yeah yeah yeah
Jessica our names are new or
gender-neutral so no matter if they're
boys or girls it's gonna be the same
name oh my friends took my name that I
loved a girl named names Ryan so pretty
oh that's my cousin Brian is cute I
guess you didn't mean when I was names
what was yours I named my daughter
Scarlett
let's not thank you too we actually
really like the names Charlotte as well
my bad actually like I wanted to name my
son atlas and then my friend [ __ ]
took that name I like ah
the longer you wait the more your names
get taken no no you know I wanted to
meet you Oh Laurie suggest I was gonna
say when I was in high school I thought
I've still thought I was gonna have kids
at some point so I thought of a few
names I always like Sonny and Farah yo
no [ __ ] in my high school there's three
kids team sunshine Suns rise and Sonny
I like sunny very happy here NES no
angel I like that like assign 1s oh and
and why honey
and then Ference like Farrah Fawcett I
like yeah whatever I think a fair though
think about Teen Mom Farrah oh never
mind never mind how do i watch Teen Mom
but also my kids are my dog today oh I
like the names Maddy and Sophie so I've
already named my kids names too cuz I
when I was pregnant with Isaac I I
thought of so many girl names but the
frickin boy names were so freaking hard
I don't even know hiking off without
Isaac
Oh though the hardness is so many
biblical um yeah well I used to say cuz
I was a lot more religious to I used to
say God named him because not until the
moment he was taken out so had a
c-section and then when he was born
there was like oh it's a boy what's his
name and we were about to name him
Xavier cuz his dad's name is Xavier so
don't wanted it with an ex and he was
like oh we could call them like we call
them X and I'm like I'm not calling my
son X
and a half it makes me think of a who's
that rapper Xzibit exhibit yeah yeah
I'll give it to you oh that would be an
amazing pick-up line for your son in bed
right would be like it's gonna give see
and they just puts his dick in here nice
are ya I relearned like I remember
staring at the hospital ceiling I'm just
like please God please help me help me I
don't know it's an oldie now because the
80s music is oldies oh yeah that's the
years ago we're like oh wait am i mate
no as 40 years ago
the 70s are always memorable we were
going up and the 50s were all these but
we were living in the 90s those only 40
years before us
well now 40 years ago was only was the
80s don't do this to me Nicky don't do
this to me please don't do this
I'm 40 I was 32 and I was born in 87 no
I guess the early 80s was 40 years ago
with 20 20 - 40 is 1980 no doing oh
sorry I'm sorry good day thank you okay
no I'm gonna put some more oh you did on
my face now through you and your fancy
pillows in the background that serves no
purpose
I pointed to my own background what
happens is once you get married and you
become a chic wife your whole bedroom
aesthetic changes you become I inspire
never never well oh my gosh
what do you do put those extra pillows
at night oh good girl you have to throw
them off
they're called throw pillows for a
reason you go mom I'm thrown back on oh
is that why they're called throw pillows
cuz y'all know I make sure that my head
and then I pretend they're facts we did
learn that today we did right learn that
today thank you for that ever my mom she
just like doesn't like gaps so she fills
it in and then then I grew up thinking a
certain thing is the fact and then I say
it someone and they're like that's not
true and I'm like yeah I am insanely
jealous
guys decorating skills though like it's
just don't you the only reason it looks
like that it's all sloppy right now is
because Steve made the bed today that
slot swap yeah I like to have them over
to cool and like very keen about she
left after of a bet a good bachelor pad
bedroom huh you know what if you go to
mine you guys have to watch this episode
I'm sorry but if you're listening you
have to just walk that is village yeah
look the green screens make this these
episodes so damn fun they do yeah with
Jeana oh yeah okay if you go to my vlog
channel in 2014 this is a plug
youtube.com slash Nikki but go back 2014
you will see you I'm pre our pre married
life my house looks like yours it is a
[ __ ] bachelor pad looking disaster
there's no art on the walls like nothing
is matching like the sheets are all like
old and nothing the beds never made
there's always like a pile of laundry on
it like it don't say dad I love you I
got your back I love you okay huh I mean
there's no excuse look at Jesse's house
it's [ __ ] beautiful it's gorgeous
this [ __ ] knows how to put her house
together she's a [ __ ] Laurette you just
drink a bottle of tequila but this has
her life together yo do you [ __ ] don't
you Gina
Gina do you make more money than me
[ __ ] do you know what time I slept last
night 6:00 in the morning
never yeah you still awake Gina posted
at 9:00 this morning and I commented if
she posted she posts for us on big mood
girls mmm and I was like Gina how are
you awake before 9:00 cuz it was like
853 and I was like this one real this is
not Gina she's like you're gonna die
early because you never sleep properly
good good
I want sweet
get so gorgeous how does that happen do
you know very expensive skin products
it's the Vietnamese writers whatever
it's your jeans yeah alright guys this
was a fun episode this was really fun
and all those bases are glowing and
beaming and the next time you see us
they probably won't be broken out in a
million pimples right I've had a look I
love it right she's naked I know it does
look like a we love you thank you to all
of our sponsors we love you too make
sure you you know check us out on
Instagram subscribe rate us on all the
things we love it it really helps our
channel out a lot and it helps us in the
podcast world and all that stuff and we
have videos coming out every so often on
Thursdays
it's like every other Thursday ish yes
special videos back on Thursdays some
that may include or not include nipples
oh yeah please like the video you
[ __ ] coward bye guys thank you